the remnants of a bridge that once
carried about 140,000 vehicles a day are
getting a new life the old Tappan Zee
Bridge spanned the Hudson River north of
New York City and demolition began last
year after construction of a modern
replacement and it leaves behind
hundreds of thousands of tons of steel
and concrete well Don Dahler is on the
beautiful fire island New York to show
us how some of those materials are
helping create new ecological habitats
Don good morning good morning
there is a 744 a Kerr reef two miles
offshore in about 60 to 70 feet of water
the state of New York is dumping
man-made materials on that reef but they
say it's not pollution it's a housing
project for undersea residents along New
York's iconic Long Island coast not far
from its shores the state is dumping a
reusable resource into its waters what
got you into this my dad was a
commercial fisherman Carl Lobo has been
navigating these waters nearly all his
life and for the past 25 years as a
marine scientist he's helping protect
them this really isn't pollution this is
beneficial to the not only to the fish
but to the ocean as well yeah putting
putting material like material from the
Tappan Zee Bridge isn't pollution it's
creating habitat that's really valued by
a lot of different fish species this
project is the largest infrastructure
project going on in the nation New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo is behind the new
four billion dollar Tappan Zee Bridge
project which is still under
construction and lurking just behind
that is what's left of the old bridge is
there a bridge heaven well there is a
bridge heaven bridge heaven is you spend
all your life above the water serving
people and then you go to bridge heaven
which is you go below the water
more than eleven thousand tons of
recycled steel and concrete will be used
to expand the state's
artificial reef program 33 barges are
hauling the material from the bridges
old footprint down the Hudson River to
the Long Island coastline it's the
largest renovation in New York history
additional square footage for marine
life that called the reefs home how is
this not just a clever way of saving
money by dumping this material in the
ocean artificial reefs are used all
across the country all across the world
it promotes the fishery it promotes the
ecosystem it promotes recreation they
become diving sites etc so there's
nothing detrimental in the materials to
the environment the materials are all
cleaned and what they provide is an
ecosystem underneath do you think this
was a good use for an old bridge I do a
lot of us had thought when we first
heard the bridge was going to be
replaced that you know this wouldn't it
be great if this is what they did with
the material and really incredibly
rapidly it was mobilized in addition to
helping the marine life the governor's
office says the expansion of the reef
will also aid local businesses it'll
encourage more sports fishing
recreational diving and potentially add
thousands of jobs to this area
fionna what a creative idea and just in
our own backyard right we would have
thought great story Don thank you